in comics there have been three
different Heroes to hold the title of
Blue Beetle first appearing in 1939 the
same year as Batman the original Blue
Beetle Dan Garrett was the first to
carry the mantle Garrett held the title
until the mid-60s when the second Blue
Beetle Ted cord took over unlike his
predecessor core didn't have a mystical
Scarab to give him superpowers he
invented all of his own crime fighting
equipment including his floating vehicle
nicknamed the bug Jaime Reyes became the
next Blue Beetle in 2006 right after
cord's death taking Garrett's Scarab and
gaining incredible superpowers in
addition to being a recurring character
in the Animated Series Batman the Brave
and the Bold and later Young Justice
Jaime's Blue Beetle first appeared in
live action opposite Booster Gold in
season 10 of Smallville